yo what is up everybody it is procedure
madame bg here with another borderlands
p sequel
video today we're going to be talking
about ultimate vault hunter mode which
is the uh
new playthrough that is coming out in
tandem with the
holodome dlc on december 16th now if you
haven't heard
ultimate vault thunder mode is coming to
borderlands for sequel
similarly to how it was in borderlands 2
it will be coming out december 16th and
it's coming out so as i said on the same
day as the holodome except the holodome
is dlc you gotta pay for that
ultimate vault hunter mode uh you don't
have to pay for that that's free so i'm
gonna make
i'm making this video just to tell all
you guys a little bit of the information
and what to expect
uh in ultimate well-tender mode so i'll
link it to the uh i'll link it in the
description below but gearbox has
released some uh
just bullet points information that you
we can all look at and be expecting to
see in
uh the ultimate ball hunter mode so
let's hop right into it so first things
is gonna be
the health and shield multipliers in
borderlands zebra sequel in ultimate
volcano mode
regular enemies are gonna get a 1.5
health multiplier and a 1.5 shield
multiplier
and ba enemies will receive a 2.5 health
multiplier and a 3.5
shield multiplier now this is
significantly less
than what was in borderlands 2
borderlands 2 had four times as much
health
which a lot of people uh got made a lot
of people complain about borderline
about the ultimate ball hunter mode
being very repetitive
and maybe not repetitive even just
very hard as in like slag became an
essential part of the
playthrough since if you didn't have
slag there was no way you were going to
kill your enemies because they were just
too much help
so uh gearbox has thankfully responded
to that in this video
in this uh new ultimate volcano mode so
we're going to be having
less health than before but still is
going to be more help than in the
previous playthroughs so they still will
be
challenged the enemy still would be more
challenging which is appropriate
enemies uh are more now more likely to
drop ammo
plus enemies and chests will give you
better gear than other playthroughs
so the first part is obviously very
self-explanatory we're gonna get more
ammo from the drops i don't think
ammo is usually too big of a deal but
maybe some people have been experiencing
that i don't know i haven't
and then enemies and chests will give
you better gear than another playthrough
so we can be expecting more greens
uh more blues more purples uh than in
the previous playthroughs and
hopefully less whites uh because
obviously
in your first playthrough you're gonna
have a lot more whites than your second
playthrough you'll probably have less
whites more greens and blues
and your fa uh this third playthrough
probably gonna even have
more of that in the same sense of having
less of the lower tier and more of the
higher tier
because you need more the higher tier to
kill the enemies that have the
increased health and shields and their
last bullet point
is that elemental weapons will be more
effective as will gear with elemental
resistance
that means your elemental weapons uh
yellow menstrual grenades
your elemental shields and oz kits
you'll have a for the weapons you'll
have higher elemental
uh damage and a more
often the higher chance of having that
elemental
effect hi that's what it is higher
chance of elemental effect
uh and the resistance on your defensive
gear will be
higher now i'm assuming this was uh
if all the elements are getting
increased i'd say it's a very good thing
and there seems like they're avoiding
what they had
with borderlands 2 which was slag became
a very dominant
it basically became slag and chuck but
this hopefully will
encourage everyone to use a plethora of
elements
except for a corrosive um but
so hopefully we will be able to use more
elemental weapons because they'll be
more effective we'll
have more intensity to use them so
that's basically all the stuff that
gearbox released
in terms of new information um there
isn't
it isn't a whole lot but it's some a few
quick things that
are interesting to note and i will
i do i am all these changes i
like i all these things to expect i'm
thinking yeah that sounds good that
sounds good that sounds good that sounds
good
i think i'm gonna enjoy i would go with
all those changes i'd be like yeah
i agree with that change that's a good
change that's a good plus so i think
that's going to be about it i told you
everything
guys i wanted to tell you and yeah
december 16th
we're gonna get that dlc and ultimate
vault hunter modes hope you guys are
ready
and i think that's gonna be it for the
video as i probably said like three
times now i hope you guys have enjoyed
this video if you have make sure you
check out my other content
because do a lot of boredoms procedural
content and that's about it
so until i make my next video and i post
it on the youtubes and you guys come and
watch it
i'll see you all later peace out